30 under 30 is a new thing we're doing
at Forbes for the first time this year
and this is sort of these are today's
disruptors and tomorrow's leaders is how
I'm sort of thinking about these are
people under the age of 30 as of january
first 2012 that we selected in 12
different categories everything from
technology to music to energy to law and
policy so it's a broad range in each
category there are three judges and
these are really prominent people in a
lot of cases Danny Meyer did food and
wine Stephanie Seymour from Gossip Girl
did entertainment and we asked them to
not only just nominate people but also
to vet the people that our reporters
came out with so incredible amount of
legwork and they unearthed some amazing
people I mean some of the people on the
lists are going to be people that people
know right Pete Cashmore from mashable's
or the CEO of Instagram but there are
also some people like an energy category
this young lady named Daniel Fong who
started something called lightsail
energy which is a renewable compressed
air if I understand it source of energy
and she started that when she was 20 and
the list is chock full of surprising and
interesting people like that
we asked them to come up with people
that you should hire now and you'll be
working for in 20 years and the so if
you take a category like music or
entertainment like you know there's some
sports figures there's some singers on
the list and all that but we're looking
really for the sports figure that's more
like a Michael Jordan and the guy that
actually is the standout in
entertainment is Mac Miller who's this
young rapper but he's got this sort of
amazing use of social media and the way
that he's leveraging himself and he's an
independent he has the number one album
in the country as an independent and
that hasn't happened in a long way so
he's a guy that is not just a performer
not just naturally talented but as a guy
that is shaping the world in his own
image and that's what we're looking for
for each of these 12 categories we are
having them come in here and there being
shot by a very very famous photographer
Harry Benson who's famous for shooting
Beatles and Henry Kissinger and has this
really iconic look he's also 80 years
old so we have this interesting young
and old sort of thing and he's very
excited about that and that also got
people very excited to come in and sit
for him because they're going to have
amazing images this is a project that
exists in multiple different platforms
there's video a beautiful print
component where we're going to have
these lovely really gorgeous photographs
of all of these people and then the list
which is only so much you can do with
that in print but then online we can do
all this other stuff and so for each of
the 30 under 30 s we instead of writing
like a long description I mean they're
under 30 so you can kind of keep this
short we had them written up in 120
characters or less or a tweet but if you
want to know more we are using LinkedIn
partnership so you can click and get
their whole thing or you can follow them
on Twitter or any of that sort of stuff
so we're giving you a gateway to sort of
interact with these people we're making
the introduction because these are
people that are going to be making noise